it is great to welcome to the program
today Nicholas Blum who is a professor
of economics at Stanford University
professor bloom so great to have you on
today yep lovely to be here thanks so
you've been studying work from home for
some time and work from home is
something that has become more prevalent
during the coronavirus social distancing
lockdowns stay at home orders whatever
phrase we want to assign to them and
there's a couple of perspectives on this
that that are increasingly prevalent one
is this is really not working for a lot
of people and a lot of types of
businesses and and for the most part
we're going to see a return to office
work as soon as it's safe the other
position is a lot of businesses are
figuring out that this is really great
they can save money on office space by
decentralizing a lot of their workers
and and it's an experiment that was
maybe forced upon us but that is a an
opportune one first question is what was
your perspective on work from home prior
to the virus and then how has your view
shifted at all if it has during the
virus sure sir prior to the virus was
actually very positive from working from
home I was involved in a large
randomized control trial out in China
working with a company called C trip
they're like the Chinese equivalent of
Expedia there are massive ten billion
dollar nasdaq listed firm with about
15,000 employees and out in shanghai we
did a big experiment on working from
home we randomized volunteers to work
from home on even and odd birthdays and
we discovered that people that work from
home were 13% more productive which is
like a huge impact is basically an extra
day a week when we looked at why that
was basically about a third of it was
they said it's just easier to work from
home it's quieter less distracting ah I
remember one you know there's a whole
series of anecdotes we've got ivory
interviewed them but Wow one of the
women she said you know I find it so
distracting in the office the woman at
the desk next door to me she clips her
toenails in the her morning breaks which
you can imagine you know you don't want
to be next to that and then the other
the other benefit of working home is of
course there's not the time lost from
commuting problems and you know that's a
the bus didn't turn up on my car
down etc so before the covet shut down
you know this is five six years ago in
China ah I did a big experiment and
since then have done a lot of media and
research from this and it was always
before now very positive from working
from home employees seem to love it quit
rates hard after they wrote this out in
China and their performance improves
okay so before we get to now what if
your and how your opinion has changed
were you able when you do a study like
that if working from home represents a
change for an employee presumably some
of the productivity increase may be
initial but it may not stay right is
that did you account for that that maybe
the new surrounding initially increases
productivity but then maybe there's some
other longer-term effect where you
return to the mean so to speak that very
interesting question so this is where
choice matters enormous Lee so the
saying from working from home is the
three great enemies are working from
home of the fridge the bed and the
television ah you know often some of us
discover that we get overcome by one of
those at least at home and so what we
found in see trip was we got we had
actually a thousand people in one
division we asked them who wants to work
from home only 500 them volunteered so
you can imagine already there's a number
of people that don't want to work from
home and and see trip I should say the
average person was commuting 40 minutes
each way in and back from work so you
know they told us this you know
isolating depressing so only half of you
who wanted it at the end of the
nine-month experiment we let them read
shoes and about half of them chose to
come back into the office and about a
third of those initially chose not to
come to change their mind
and you then sir in the longer on the
impact on working from home was almost
twice as big so this was like 25% why
was that and the answers a lot of people
think I do really well working from home
they go home and then they just can't
handle it they you know end up watching
TV they sleep in too late et cetera so
it's not so much that people get worse
over time is that you discover that it
either works or doesn't work for you so
I'm not so much truer against working
for home I'm very pro-choice on it and
allowing people to experiment okay so
now we get into you've continued
your study through this experiment this
additional phase of experimentation
forced upon a lot more people than the
thousand people in your study globally
what if anything has modified your view
that you've seen so right now I'm uh you
know very negative and working under
Kovac why there are four reasons that
there's a big problem that's completely
different from my study firstly its
children so a lot of us had kids you
know I have a four-year-old that runs
into the room she calls me doo doo and
we're like shout doo doo time to play
you know my older kid plays the bagpipes
I don't know it's just quite worse but
you know kids kids is hugely distracting
that's quite an instrument to have
happening in the next room over yeah
yeah I think the only thing worse than
playing the bagpipes is practicing the
back it's like the same song over and
over again but with each mystery you
know it's painful and I live on the west
coast at California soar in a wooden
framed house that has very little sound
proofing so one is kids you know we see
to it wouldn't have allowed people know
if no firmly would allow people to work
from home or kids normally around
secondly is you need your own room
that's not your bedroom I mean even in
my I don't know if I moved by the way
you know there's a bed behind me in this
room it's like I'm lucky am I in a room
to work in but a lot of people are
sharing apartment rooms I had a
colleague of mine that when I asked I
could see you know her toothbrush and
the background she was taking a call
from the bathroom the third factor is
choice as I mentioned on the kovat we
don't choose and in fact there's an
interesting study at Chicago that looks
carefully across all jobs in America and
estimates only around one third of jobs
can be done effectively at home so the
other 2/3 that either hearted or
impossible I mean being a waiter or a
dentist or a pilot and then finally was
full-time so right now we're working
from home five days a week in see trip
we only had four days a week because
that fifth day is critical to come into
the office to have you know both to be
motivated and inspired and also to be
creative so just to give you a figure if
you look at surveys from the US Census
before Co vyd are 28% of graduates
worked from home at least one day a week
so it's quite common amongst you know so
more senior employees managers etc but
only 2% did full-time five days a week
so five days a week is really extreme
it's like fanatical working from home it
was extremely rare beforehand and the
reason is you need some face-to-face
time in the office right now right that
was going to be my other question about
the the social interactions which is the
mental health effects of people maybe
dramatically reducing their social
interactions over the course of a week
maybe this also leads to people not
taking as good care of themselves I just
don't know do we have any data about
that yes a mental health you know two
data points one is just in secret when
he asked at the end of the study half
the people voted to come back into the
office we asked them why and interviewed
them in detail and they said depression
loneliness isolation if you look now
that two kind of indicators that are
coming out that war and I think of as a
kind of a tsunami of mental health
problems are calls to suicide helplines
have risen several hundred percent and
then you know anecdotally in China the
stories of you know a surge of divorces
so their data is only starting to come
out but I'm you know I feel very worried
that people force to isolate in fact is
even worse than full-time welcome home
because you can't go out in the evenings
or the weekend either so I think we're
stirring up a mental health time bomb
and as you point out mental health is
also very strongly associated physical
health in fact another good indicator of
this is on retirement in countries where
you have statutory retirement like in
Germany you have to retire at 55 you see
a very large deterioration in health and
a big spike in death rates when people
retire so actually it turns out you know
believe it or not work is actually good
for us in terms of health and so being
forced at home I think is very
problematic for health one of the things
that I've read about here in the u.s. in
terms of the economic effects of those
who are on unemployment versus those who
are able to work from home is of course
what we would colloquially call a white
collar versus blue collar divide which
is that there are probably some pretty
notable economic disparities and who
even has the opportunity to have a
conversation about working from home
versus who either is going in or you
don't really have a job right now so if
work from home were to become more
prevalent is there some way in which it
might increase economic inequality in
the country maybe I mean it certainly is
now I think now it's far more
problematic because there is no office
equivalent so you're right that jobs
that work remotely are obviously non
physically they're non physical there's
very few physical jobs you can do at
home I mean maybe if you're making
high-end handbags you can make them at
home but pretty much physical jobs in
the office the other issue is you have
to be a job that's based on you
evaluated by measured on output rather
than inputs so for example if you're
doing something I just you know I'm an
academic so people can evaluate my
research and teacher and to see me
sitting at my desk they just look at
what I do but the number of lower
skilled jobs tend to be based on inputs
and you actually got to physically
observe the person so in the long run
yes it will be easier for higher skill
graduate jobs to be at home that's
probably less of an issue then you can
still go into work of your ah you know
lower skilled the problem is much more
right now that you've literally been
forced to lose your job and of course
you're losing skills as well so I think
the bigger issue is now you know the one
positive I take on a lot of this is I
think welcome home is going to slightly
empty out the center of cities which is
going to address to some extent the
affordability crisis so the other big
you know issue is San Francisco New York
many large cities become so expensive we
can't live in them anymore you know the
upside of working from home is people
move out a bit prices would drop in
central cities but at least those
workers that need to be in work every
day can more easily afford to live there
yeah so that was actually one of the
things I was going to ask ask you about
here's another one since you mentioned
it and I have no idea whether this is
something you've looked at it's a bit
out further outside of the scope of what
we've been talking about so far which is
there was this initial panic among some
that if work from home if companies
figure out we don't really need these
offices that there would be a crash in
commercial real estate and it would be
absolutely terrible economically but
then there was a counter-argument that I
read which was interesting which was
well a lot of those companies if they
did pull back from full-time office
space would likely find new places that
would be available for meetings
co-working spaces on an
as needed sort of basis and that it
would not be as objectively decimating
to the commercial leasing industry is
this something you've considered or
looked at at all or have any opinion of
you know I exam somewhat pessimistic on
commercial office space you are okay
post post you know the return so in the
short run I mean the short I'm a Kovac
could honestly be one to two years who
knows when they find a vaccine but if he
took post vaccine post the current
pandemic you could easily see a big
surge in people working from home two
days a week so it's a good example
London in 2012 shut down the center of
the city for three weeks because the
Olympics they didn't want the congestion
for the Olympics and after that there
was almost a doubling of working from
home of firms affected they just found
it worked quite well they went back to
it but on a part-time basis so imagine
we rolled this out and everyone goes
from working from home basically no days
a week to two days a week you can see
that's roughly a forty percent to drop
and demand for desks you are right you
still need meeting rooms and in fact the
way the work of the future I think is
like to be arranged is you do all your
meetings your lunches your coffees your
group activities on say Monday Wednesday
Friday when you're in the office Tuesday
Thursday the whole team goes home and
that's when you have your quiet time and
maybe you're one and once so you know if
you have a one-on-one discussion about
work you can actually do it pretty
effectively on a video call increasingly
so really yeah I think so in the normal
you know for me I used to take regular
phone calls every morning with various
you know co-authors around the u.s. and
internationally it was all by phone now
i all do i do it my video conference cuz
you you need that sense of interpersonal
relationship but i think the center of
cities will become cheaper the other
more out there impact i think i worry
abouts political polarization so there's
a view that in the 50s we all watch the
same TV we basically lived in similar
areas and we went to work with other
people and that moderated our views by
now we consume different media you know
the left and the right go to different
you know television stations americans
in particular increasingly polarised and
where they live you can opt from charter
schools into different schools the one
moderating factor has been we all at
least have to go to the same workplace
and work with people so if you're on a
hard right or hard left you have to talk
with others over lunch if suddenly we
are working from home you know there's
nothing to stop the extremes just moving
out to the fringes so you know that's
another impact oddly enough work was the
single biggest moderating factor it
appears from data now on our political
opinion such that's interested that is
that is certainly less one that is less
discussed in in everything that I've
been reading and certainly one not to be
dismissed because it is a major problem
as you point out currently in in the
United States we've been speaking with
Nicholas Blum professor of economics at
Stanford University I so appreciate your
time today
great thanks very much lovely to talk